this is just not an ordinary suit this
is actually a bulletproof suit they go
about to chain two chains I'm going over
the top some time and right now we want
to check our most expensive is [ __ ] just
definitely crazy
what out what up is two chains we back
most expensive is [ __ ] and today we're
gonna talk to my man Jay is from
garrison bespoke super swag on the Zeus
man this is another kind of suit
something I never would have thought of
and I'm a rapper let's check it out nice
to meet you Jay what's going on you're
looking nice today spiffy man I don't
know what I was thinking when I tried to
comb all black your Rose Street where
swag your changing fashion yeah yeah
everything you've been doing is kind of
like showing that yeah it makes you
tailor to the cameras
everything 2 Chainz been doing is
changing the game fashion and what we
got here looks like a you know right
little church just look like a regular
old church suit but with the big fella
hairy though this is actually a
bulletproof suit so it's made to protect
you up to like 32 cow it's a diamond
nanotube technology developed by the US
Army I'll be tested this is Adam you can
see from here is actually tested earlier
today for ooh yeah award we put it on a
mannequin and we shot it at the gun
range there's a video of them shooting
right here the gun range you got dude oh
look I got a tone everything everything
and then reload I'm set and that's and
he didn't get that for you nothing
doesn't go through it all bulletproof
pinstripe shirts suit so bulletproof
vests aren't against the law or they
just let you get one Jay talk to me how
did you how were you able to come up
with this you can have these here you
can have them mate you just can't really
bring them across the border
this is a canadian-based company all
right I got some people you have to
notice people have some places some
places all these can be made bulletproof
too
the other jackets if I wanted to give
this jacket may be bulletproof because
it's about five more on to the ribbon at
least at a minimum but 15 most expensive
[ __ ] right leg or don't do it at all
yeah you know this looks good on it
actually goes with my outfit I would
hate for you to want it back so just to
not even give you any confusion I'm
going to take it off your hands
and that's how we gonna start our
relationship cool all right
it's good bang bang tell you though some
crazy suits
I mean bulletproof suits bulletproof
suits people bulletproof suit I mean I
imagine going to church in a bulletproof
suit you really need to find the Lord
$20,000 a little excess you tell me
leave a comment subscribe to the GQ
chump for more most expensive [ __ ] bang